remind me how many kinds of purse have
we looked at under the heading of
induction what was the very first one I
showed you was a series wasn't what else
have we looked at we looked at
divisibility I did tell you I eluded the
fact that you could do once in calculus
in it or geometry okay this is different
again it's an inequality curve okay but
Matt every time we look at one the
framework stays the same you always test
assume proof
explain every single time if it's
mathematical induction okay that's
called the principle of mathematical
induction okay but when you get to the
hard step the purge step right it's
always a little bit different because
the things you're trying to prove are a
little bit different okay for instance
you know when we looked at divisibility
just now right they don't give you a
statement so you have to make one up
right that's different from when you
looked at before here again it will be
slightly different one more time okay
at the beginning it's still the same
though let's test first allowable value
is N equals 1 do be careful with this by
the way even though you can sort of get
into autopilot on what these are
watch out firstly they don't always
start at 1 they might start at 0
well they might start at 4 or anything
they like okay secondly you have to be
careful about the rules at the allowable
allowable values tank you know I don't
just write this for kicks right
sometimes it's not that can a lot of
things you have oh there are some
examples on your sheet
what's it look like even though you
normally start with the left-hand side
here for reasons that will become clear
in about two minutes I'm going to start
with the right-hand side
what's it equal to
it's one plus three which is four what
is the left-hand side equal to the left
hand side is 4 2 power 1 which is 4 okay
now at this point what was I seeking to
prove that it's true for the first
allowable value okay now because I
started with the right-hand side and now
I'm ending with the left-hand side here
I can say this that is greater than or
equal to the right hand side subtle
difference if I had started with the
left and then down the right I'd say
right hand side is less than or equal to
the left hand side I just find it
confusing to have the left on the right
and the right on the left in the
inequalities switched around these are
hot enough let's just keep things the
way they are ok no problems there's a
test what do I assume I'll just stick my
k's in right assume it's true for N
equals K where K is the same kind of
number that n is so looks like it's for
the K it's greater than equal to 1 plus
3 K now if we get down to our work step
proof
okay left inside no problem that's just
sticking it in what happens to the
right-hand side when I am collect like
terms and that kind of thing
this guy's gonna become what 3 K + 3 + 1
3 K + 4 this is what I'm looking for
okay now said this you know subtle
differences in the different varieties
of induction proofs and what happens in
this step okay so here's what I'm gonna
do
usually you look at one side then you
work with it and then at some point you
can put in the Assumption right and you
could do it that way I think it's gonna
be more straightforward if for you if
you actually start off with the
assumption right away okay my assumption
for to the K is greater than you could
have that okay so I already know this is
true and now I can start working on it
now before I looked at this and I tried
to twist and turn it so I could use this
this time I start here and I'm gonna try
and twist and turn this so that I get
back can you see it's a subtle
difference it's always it's a bit like
direct proof but I'm still a student
thing so it's not exactly the same now
you told me you look at this what would
you say is the most direct way I could
go from here to here now you've got two
choices because you've got two sides of
the inequality don't you okay if you
look at the right hand side the
difference between that right hand side
in this right hand side is three so I
could add three to both sides and once I
would be correct and then I have to work
on the other one alternatively I could
multiply this side by four and then I'll
get this and then I have to work with
that side and see what I can do okay now
which do you think would be better do
you keep multiplying by four what do you
think adding three
well let's test your theory shall we
multiply left-hand side by 4 you get 4
to the k plus 1 sure enough okay now on
the right hand side you get 4 plus 12
okay okay
right now what were we trying to set out
to prove this is where I want to end up
I do not have this
so what could I do have I done something
wrong
you just told me to one-to-one before
it's not negative it's not that the
inequality went the other way
this is not what I'm trying to prove is
it an answer is nor it is not what I'm
trying to prove guess what
it's better than what I'm trying to
prove think about this think about it I
want to prove that this thing is big
it's bigger than that
okay we have a look carefully at this
thing
3 k + 4 + 12 k + 4 right so it's like
with my black one go okay you're like I
want to prove that you know some number
X is bigger than 10 okay this is what
I'm setting out to prove and I do some
work I use an assumption and somehow I
prove that it's bigger than 100 like oh
no I haven't proved it
of course you proved it and then some
right if it's bigger than 100 surely
it's bigger than 10 right because 100 is
bigger than 10 so here's the way that I
will write it okay four plus two okay I
will say but four plus twelve K right
this guy is greater than or equal to 3k
plus four which is what I'm after right
now
stop why is that I keep asking this
right in purse
why is everything right how can I say
this because it is not always true right
it's it's only true because K is a
certain kind of number by all of you
people who are like I'm in a hurry I
always have to write this I'm just going
to skip it for now so I'll go do the
rest of these 50 questions to not
skipper because is it is crucial to the
argument this is only true because K is
a positive integer okay that's why this
is bigger than that if it's negative it
blows up so beenin that's true I can say
this this is bigger than this which in
turn is bigger than that okay nananana
calm down it's not the squeezed law
because you need these guys by the way
think about it you know what these look
like don't you like if I put in an X
instead of a K you could graph these
what's this guy doing he's going whee
what's this guy doing he's going right
this is not the squeezed LaHood okay I
know it looks like it cuz the
inequalities but it's not they are not
squeezing anything okay all I've got is
a series of inequalities that I want I
want these guys which is evidently true
okay do you see the way it works if
something is bigger than these big
numbers going to be given that smaller
number I'm done you can explain from
there okay what was important do your
assumption as usual when you're doing
your proof where do you begin
I'm usually you start with the
assumption you don't need to massage it
at all event or stick it in just go
right off the bat
think of the quickest way you can get
one side of the inequality looking right
doesn't matter which one
just whichever is going to be most
convenient for you to work with you you
chose correctly x 4 is a better often
you add 3 it's not clear at all okay so
there you go hope that makes sense in
case you're wondering it is easier to
generally prove that things are bigger
than other things then to prove things
are less than whole things and that
seems like what's the difference okay
well it's the same as the difference
between these two things I can prove
that out I can actually prove that is
greater than B it's actually much easier
to prove that the difference between
them is positive okay because I know all
kinds of things are that positive
numbers they follow a lots of rules that
I'm very familiar with this one not so
much so you know they're equivalent one
is easier than the other okay